اسبوع حاسم تعيشه فرنسا في ظل معركه قانون
التقاعد ثماني نقابات عماليه دعت الى
تظاهرات مليونيه واضراب تحت عنوان اغلاق
فرنسا ياتي ذلك بالتزامن مع دراسه مجلس
الشيوخ لمشروع القانون لمواجهه ذلك حشدت
السلطات الاف عناصر الشرطه انتشروا في
شوارع العاصمه بشكل خاص ولكن ايضا في معظم
المدن الفرنسيه حيث سجل خروج 260 تظاهره
لكن ذلك لم يمنع من وقوع اشتباكات بين
المتظاهرين والشرطه استخدمت الاخيره
خلالها الغاز المسيل للدموع ووقعت بعض
الاصابات في صفوف متظاهرين ويشمل الاضراب
قطاعات كثيره من بينها الصحه والتعليم
والمواصلات والطاقه حيث سجل مشاركه نحو
40% من المدرسين بهذا الاضراب في حين الغت
هيئه الطيران المدني ما بين 20 الى 30% من
رحلات الطيران واثر ذلك على رحلات الطيران
والقطارات بين فرنسا وبريطانيا بشكل خاص
النقابات تسعى لان يتواصل الاضراب لايام
عديده وذلك بهدف ايقاف فرنسا وشل اقتصادها
من اجل اجبار الحكومه على التراجع
فدهوك العربيه باريس